This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. As you fly into Pearson Airport in Toronto, you can see Canada's largest city takes shape beneath you. Downtown there is a dense core of tall, glassy buildings along the waterfront of Lake Ontario. Outside of that, short, single-family homes sprawl out in every direction. This is the view reporter Jay Copern saw on his window as he moved to Canada in 2019. In my head, I knew exactly where I wanted to live, a real big city apartment, like the classic brownstone walk-ups you might see in New York, or the three-story stone apartment buildings with iron staircases you see in Montreal.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。当你飞抵多伦多的皮尔逊机场时，你可以看到加拿大最大的城市在脚下逐渐成形。市中心沿安大略湖滨有一片密集的高层玻璃建筑群。而在那之外，低矮的单户住宅向四面八方蔓延开来。这就是记者杰伊·科本2019年搬到加拿大时，从窗户看到的景象。我脑海中清楚地知道自己想住什么样的地方：那种真正的大城市公寓，就像你在纽约看到的经典褐砂石步梯公寓，或者在蒙特利尔看到的带有铁艺楼梯的三层石砌公寓楼。
I had this romantic notion of living in one of those early 20th century apartments. You know, great lighting, a little exposed brick. Maybe even a nice fireplace. Is that really so much to ask for? But at first, Jay struggled to find anything like that dream apartment in Toronto. Instead, as a renter, I found myself looking at a lot of 400 square foot condos, high up in some shiny and soulless towers, and some dank basement apartments under some rich person's house.
我曾对居住在那种20世纪初的公寓里抱有浪漫的幻想。你知道的，采光极好，带点裸露的砖墙，甚至可能还有一个漂亮的壁炉。这要求真的很高吗？但起初，杰伊在多伦多很难找到那种梦想中的公寓。相反，作为一名租房者，我发现自己看的全是些400平方英尺的公寓，位于某些光鲜亮丽却毫无灵魂的高塔里，或者是某些富人住宅下阴暗潮湿的地下室公寓。
All of these options were really expensive. I kept wondering where are all the low rise apartment buildings? The kinds of buildings you find in abundance in Montreal or New York or Chicago. J was looking for a middle ground and not finding it, something in between the extremes of single-family homes and big generic condo towers, but there just weren't a lot of middle-sized rental buildings in Toronto. Lots of cities are in the same boat as Toronto, places like Los Angeles, Seattle, Boston,
所有这些选择都非常昂贵。我一直在想，那些低层公寓楼都去哪儿了？就是你在蒙特利尔、纽约或芝加哥随处可见的那种建筑。杰伊当时在寻找一种中间地带却一无所获，即介于单户住宅和大型普通公寓楼这两个极端之间的选择，但多伦多确实没有多少中等规模的租赁建筑。许多城市和多伦多处于同样的境地，比如洛杉矶、西雅图、波士顿，
and Vancouver. All of these cities have a pronounced lack of mid-sized buildings. Right now, this is one of the biggest use for urban planners. They even have a name for it. The Missing Middle The term Missing Middle can be confusing. It does not refer to middle class housing. The missing middle is strictly about architectural scale. The middle in this case refers to a huge
以及温哥华。所有这些城市都明显缺乏中型建筑。目前，这是城市规划者面临的最大难题之一。他们甚至给它起了一个名字：缺失的中产住宅（The Missing Middle）。“缺失的中产住宅”这个术语可能会让人困惑。它指的并不是中产阶级的住房。“缺失的中产住宅”完全是指建筑规模。这里的“中产”指的是一大
swath of housing options. Duplexes, triplexes, townhouses, courtyard buildings, and low-rise apartment buildings. Buildings of this size have an outsized effect on the city. Cities with these medium-density housing options have a lot of benefits. For starters, they're less expensive to live in. Cities with lots of middle housing just have more choice in the housing market. The options are more diverse. They have more robust neighborhoods and options for families. By contrast, cities without middle housing tend to be harder for pretty much everyone except for the wealthy, and they tend to be more segregated. So it's easy to see why there's some conflation between the missing middle and the lack of middle income housing options. The two are absolutely related.
类住房选择。复式公寓、三联排公寓、联排别墅、庭院建筑和低层公寓楼。这种规模的建筑对城市有着巨大的影响。拥有这些中等密度住房选择的城市有很多好处。首先，它们的居住成本更低。拥有大量中产住宅的城市在住房市场上拥有更多选择。选择更加多样化。它们拥有更稳固的社区和适合家庭的居住方案。相比之下，没有中产住宅的城市对除富人以外的几乎所有人来说都更难生存，而且它们往往更加隔离。所以很容易理解为什么人们会将“缺失的中产住宅”与“中等收入住房选择的缺乏”混为一谈。这两者绝对是相关的。
Toronto's missing middle is pretty extreme, and the main culprit for this is, I hope you're excited, early 20th century zoning laws. In the late 1800s, there was a big wave of immigration to cities across North America. In Toronto, there was already an established population of British immigrants, but this new wave included a lot
多伦多的“缺失的中产住宅”现象非常极端，而罪魁祸首——希望你们对此感到兴奋——是20世纪初的土地分区法。19世纪末，北美各城市迎来了一波巨大的移民潮。在多伦多，当时已经有了一定规模的英国移民人口，但这一新浪潮中包含了许多
of Eastern European immigrants. New multi-unit tenement buildings cropped up to house these new people, but there was a backlash against these new immigrants in the 1912 Toronto Band apartment buildings in most of the city. This band was an early version of exclusionary zoning. The kind of residential zoning where large swathes of urban centres are reserved for single-family homes and only single-family homes. Cities across North America were passing these kinds of zoning laws, and they were driven by a false perception that apartment buildings were dens of inequity.
东欧移民。新的多单元廉租公寓楼拔地而起，以安置这些新来者，但多伦多在1912年出现了针对这些新移民的强烈抵制，禁止在城市大部分地区建造公寓楼。这项禁令是排他性分区法的早期版本。这种住宅分区将城市中心的大片区域保留给单户住宅，且仅限单户住宅。北美各城市都在通过此类分区法，而它们的驱动力是一种错误的观念，即公寓楼是罪恶的温床。
They were often referred to as French flats. There was a kind of association of Frenchness with dubious morality. This is Richard Dennis. He's Professor Emeritus at University College London, and he's kind of the historian of apartments in Toronto. Developers at the time were trying to associate their buildings with European class and luxury. Instead, they were met with unhinged accusations of immorality. Richard Dennis says this detaste for apartment buildings in the early 20th century was based on racist and sexist attitudes that were reflected in the media. The editor of the Canadian
它们常被称为“法式公寓”。当时有一种将“法式”与可疑道德联系起来的倾向。这位是理查德·丹尼斯。他是伦敦大学学院的荣誉退休教授，也是多伦多公寓历史的研究者。当时的开发商试图将他们的建筑与欧洲的阶级和奢华联系起来。然而，他们迎来的却是疯狂的道德败坏指控。理查德·丹尼斯表示，20世纪初对公寓楼的这种厌恶，是基于媒体所反映的种族主义和性别歧视态度。加拿大《建筑师与建筑商》杂志的编辑
architect and builder wrote successive editorials where he condemned them and he condemned them on these grounds that a woman would have nothing to do and they would kind of go off the rails. The newspaper articles about apartments at this time are wild. I dug up a bunch and there are lots of references to how apartments are unsanitary and poor for the morals of the city. There's this quote here from the Globe newspaper in 1912. Quote, Toronto must look to her building laws or she will be overrun with a plague of disease breeding tenements and apartment houses." At the time, Canada's elites were largely British. Toronto's puritanical wasps were scared these apparently filthy apartments
写了连续的社论，以女性会无所事事并因此“误入歧途”为由对公寓进行了谴责。当时关于公寓的报纸文章简直荒唐至极。我翻找了一堆，里面有很多关于公寓如何不卫生、如何败坏城市道德的说法。这里引用1912年《环球报》的一段话：“多伦多必须审视其建筑法规，否则她将被滋生疾病的廉租房和公寓楼瘟疫所淹没。”当时，加拿大的精英阶层主要是英国人。多伦多清教徒式的盎格鲁-撒克逊新教徒（WASPs）担心这些看似肮脏的公寓
would be too tempting for nice British families. And they also alluded to the idea of race suicide. And the fear was that if people went and lived in an apartment, well they'd never become parents because they'd find that life was on the one hand so comfortable, but also spatially, relatively constricted, they would never start a family. And that's where you would get this idea of right suicide, the birthright would decline, and British families would be overtaken by immigrant families. To be clear, these articles don't reflect the reality of what departments were like in Toronto. Early apartment buildings were actually aimed at the city's elite.
会对体面的英国家庭产生太大的诱惑。他们还暗示了“种族自杀”的概念。人们担心，如果人们去住公寓，他们就永远不会成为父母，因为他们会发现生活一方面很舒适，但空间上又相对狭窄，他们永远不会组建家庭。这就是“种族自杀”观念的由来，出生率会下降，英国家庭会被移民家庭所取代。需要明确的是，这些文章并不反映当时多伦多公寓的真实情况。早期的公寓楼实际上是针对城市精英阶层的。
The first two were built around the turn of the century and were so luxurious that in a lot of the units they didn't have kitchens. You were expected to order meals from the building's restaurant. They were often called apartment hotels, and they were marketed to the great and the good. But apartment living was at odds without Toronto wanted to be seen. Well, on the one hand, it had this view of itself as a city of homes and a city of homes meant single family dwellings
最初的两栋建筑建于世纪之交，极其奢华，许多单元甚至没有厨房。你被期望从大楼的餐厅订餐。它们通常被称为“公寓酒店”，并向社会名流推销。但公寓生活与多伦多希望展现的形象格格不入。一方面，它将自己视为一座“家园之城”，而“家园之城”意味着单户住宅
and home ownership. Toronto was growing rapidly. It went from 200,000 people at the turn of the century to half a million in 1920, with that developer started buying up land to build apartments, but they faced fierce resistance from the city, including smear campaigns. They tend to stress, you know, that either the architect or the developer has got links to either to the United States or to Montreal. Which, if you're from Toronto, are some incredibly slanderous accusations.
和房屋所有权。多伦多当时发展迅速。人口从世纪之交的20万增加到1920年的50万。开发商开始购买土地建造公寓，但他们遭到了来自城市的激烈抵制，包括抹黑运动。他们倾向于强调，建筑师或开发商与美国或蒙特利尔有联系。如果你是多伦多人，这些都是极其诽谤性的指控。
So there was a kind of tension between the people who saw the future of the city as being that kind of metropolitan centre, which would attract people who wanted luxury housing, but perhaps not just luxury suburban housing, but a downtown apartment where they were close to things, to entertainment and to those kinds of activities. So, apartment builders had one vision of an urban centre, but it was at odds with another vision of Toronto as a city of homes. Tension between those people and the people who saw Toronto as a nice suburban domestic paradise
因此，在那些将城市未来视为大都市中心的人（他们会吸引想要豪华住房，但也许不仅仅是豪华郊区住宅，而是靠近娱乐和活动场所的市中心公寓的人）之间存在一种张力。所以，公寓建筑商对城市中心有一种愿景，但这与多伦多作为“家园之城”的另一种愿景相冲突。这种张力存在于这些人与那些将多伦多视为一个美好的郊区家庭天堂的人之间，
where everybody would have their own little plot out in more and more distant suburbs. These attitudes prevailed across North America and led to a whole bunch of cities banning apartment buildings and wealthy neighborhoods. This movement was driven by the chief planner of St. Louis, a man named Harland Bartholomew. Bartholomew was the architect of single use zoning in St. Louis, and he was hired by cities across North America like Memphis, Chattanooga, Rochester, and even Vancouver to design restrictive zoning policies. When explaining his policies, Bartholomew was explicitly racist. This is a direct quote. Bartholomew said his plan in St. Louis was
在那里，每个人都可以在越来越遥远的郊区拥有自己的一小块土地。这些态度在北美盛行，导致一大批城市禁止在富人区建造公寓楼。这场运动由圣路易斯的首席规划师哈兰·巴塞洛缪推动。巴塞洛缪是圣路易斯单一用途分区法的建筑师，他被孟菲斯、查塔努加、罗切斯特甚至温哥华等北美各城市聘请来设计限制性的分区政策。在解释其政策时，巴塞洛缪表现得极其种族主义。这是一段直接引语。巴塞洛缪说，他在圣路易斯的计划是
to preserve the more desirable residential neighborhoods and to prevent movement into finer residential districts by colored people. Bartholomew had a big influence on urban planners across the continent, but one city went above and beyond with restrictive zoning, Toronto. In 1912, the city passed by law 6061, which banned all apartment buildings and residential areas. At the time, most apartment buildings
为了保护更理想的住宅区，并防止有色人种进入更高级的住宅区。巴塞洛缪对整个大陆的城市规划者产生了巨大影响，但有一个城市在限制性分区方面走得更远，那就是多伦多。1912年，该市通过了6061号附例，禁止在住宅区建造所有公寓楼。当时，大多数公寓楼
were a few stories high. The kind of buildings we would call middle housing today. The by-law included a list of streets where apartment buildings were forbidden. And that list included pretty much every street in Toronto except for the largest commercial avenues. On those streets, all you could build were detached single-family homes. Lots of clever developers actually found a way to profit off Toronto's anti-apartment hysteria,
只有几层高。也就是我们今天所说的“中产住宅”。该附例列出了一份禁止建造公寓楼的街道名单。这份名单几乎涵盖了多伦多的每一条街道，除了最大的商业大道。在那些街道上，你只能建造独立的单户住宅。许多聪明的开发商实际上找到了从多伦多的反公寓歇斯底里中获利的方法，
including one man named Alfred Hors. Hors was bought a plot of land in downtown Toronto and basically threatened to build apartments there until the neighbours bought it from him. And this is a characteristic which happens several times after 1905 in other buildings where basically developers threaten to a development. And then they persuade the other local residents that they'll buy the land instead and of course they buy it at an inflated price. So you make your money without having to do anything at all. Having done this once,
其中包括一个名叫阿尔弗雷德·霍斯的人。霍斯在多伦多市中心买了一块地，基本上威胁说要在那儿盖公寓，直到邻居们把它买下来。这是一种在1905年后的其他建筑项目中多次出现的特征，基本上开发商会威胁要进行开发。然后他们说服其他当地居民买下这块地，当然，他们是以虚高的价格买下的。所以你什么都不用做就能赚到钱。做过一次之后，
he then promptly buys the lot on the other side of the road, which was also a vacant corner lot. It was on that lot that Alfred Haas made good on his threat to build an apartment building in Toronto, which he called Spadina Gardens. It was only the fourth apartment building ever constructed in the city, and it received real pushback. The city denied Halls of Permit, and even rushed through a by-law in an effort to stop his construction. But Halls didn't care. He started building Spadina Gardens without a permit.
他随即买下了马路对面的一块地，那也是一块空置的转角地。正是在那块地上，阿尔弗雷德·霍斯兑现了他的威胁，在多伦多建造了一栋公寓楼，他称之为“斯帕迪纳花园”。这是该市建造的第四栋公寓楼，并受到了真正的抵制。市政府拒绝了霍斯的许可，甚至匆忙通过了一项附例试图阻止他的施工。但霍斯不在乎。他开始在没有许可的情况下建造斯帕迪纳花园。
He ignored the by-law, and somehow he got away with it. In fact, Halls apartment building is still there, and it's now the oldest in-use apartment building in the city. I actually had a chance to check it out, and it's an incredible historical artifact. A low-rise apartment built in Toronto before the city banned these types of buildings. It's the kind of place that could have been everywhere in Toronto, if it weren't for exclusionary zoning. The building is four stories high with reddish brown brick.
他无视了附例，不知何故他竟然逃脱了惩罚。事实上，霍斯的公寓楼至今仍在那里，现在是该市最古老的在用公寓楼。我实际上有机会去看了看，它是一个令人难以置信的历史文物。一栋在多伦多禁止此类建筑之前建造的低层公寓。如果不是因为排他性分区，它本可以遍布多伦多。这栋建筑有四层高，红棕色的砖墙。
It's got that classic pre-war look with bay windows, elegant detailing and this unusual striped effect in the stone on the ground floor. usual striped effect in the stone, the ground floor. I don't think I want to go up the stairs if you want to take the very ancient elevator. I mean, I kind of want to see the ancient elevators. Is that room for two in it? Yeah. It's one of the pretty old school ones that you'd expect to see it like a... Yeah, yeah. And it is the original one. This is Charlotte Mickey, and she's kind of the unofficial historian of Spadina Gardens.
它有着经典的战前外观，带有凸窗、优雅的细节和底层石材上不寻常的条纹效果。底层石材上不寻常的条纹效果。如果你想乘坐那部非常古老的电梯，我想我不想上楼。我是说，我有点想看看那些古老的电梯。里面有两人空间吗？是的。它是那种你期望在……中看到的非常老派的电梯。是的，是的。而且它是原装的。这位是夏洛特·米奇，她是斯帕迪纳花园非官方的历史学家。
And she kindly let me poke my nose around the building. It's straight through the door. It's just down the hall. I'll show you something for so because we were talking about the glass so this is I think one of the most charming. This is more like the kind of place I wanted to find when I moved here. It's a low rise apartment with character and community. Do you feel like you have a sense of community within the building? Yes we do absolutely. No we all help each other out and we all know each other. Which is really nice.
她好心地让我四处看看这栋建筑。直接穿过那扇门。就在走廊尽头。我给你看点东西，因为我们刚才在谈论玻璃，所以我认为这是最迷人的地方之一。这更像是我搬到这里时想找的那种地方。这是一栋有特色、有社区感的低层公寓。你觉得在大楼里有社区感吗？是的，我们绝对有。不，我们都互相帮助，我们都认识彼此。这真的很好。
It's thoughtfully designed, it's airy and bright, not at all the pit of amorality and disease that those newspapers depicted. In fact, this building was marketed to the city's more privileged residents. That's still true today. It's more than a little out of my price range. And where does this go back here? So this is stepping off the back side of the kitchen. There's a little back corner. So that's the first thing. So you can come through there or you can come through
它设计周到，通风明亮，一点也不像那些报纸所描绘的道德和疾病的深渊。事实上，这栋建筑是向城市中更优越的居民推销的。这一点今天依然适用。它超出了我的预算。这后面通向哪里？这是从厨房后面走出来。有一个小后角。所以这是第一件事。所以你可以从那里进来，或者你可以从
here. Oh, and it loops right round to the entrance. To the entrance. And control. You see what I mean now, but this sort of circular flow like yeah. Spanana Gardens is not affordable housing. In fact, it's pretty expensive to rent there today. Middle housing doesn't necessarily mean cheaper housing, but one of the reasons that it's so expensive is because there's not enough middle housing to go around. Toronto could have had similar buildings across the city. This building would not be so remarkable in many other cities like Chicago or New York.
这里进来。哦，它绕回了入口。到入口。还有控制。你现在明白我的意思了吧，这种环形流动……是的。斯帕迪纳花园不是经济适用房。事实上，今天在那儿租房相当昂贵。中产住宅并不一定意味着更便宜的住房，但它之所以如此昂贵，原因之一是中产住宅供不应求。多伦多本可以在全市拥有类似的建筑。这栋建筑在芝加哥或纽约等许多其他城市并不会显得如此引人注目。
But the apartment ban of 1912 stopped developers from building all kinds of apartments. The nice expensive places like this for the city's wealthy and fashionable residents, but also the kind of middle housing that's affordable for middle-class families. Spadana Gardens didn't kick off a trend of rogue developers defying the bylaws and putting up apartment buildings everywhere because after Bylaw 6061 passed, city planners weren't finished with their war on apartment buildings. As Toronto expanded outward in the 60s, city planners designated residential neighborhoods as in violet, meaning they couldn't be touched by new development.
但1912年的公寓禁令阻止了开发商建造各种公寓。既包括像这样为城市富裕和时尚居民准备的高档昂贵场所，也包括适合中产阶级家庭的经济型中产住宅。斯帕迪纳花园并没有引发一股流氓开发商无视附例、到处建造公寓楼的潮流，因为在6061号附例通过后，城市规划者并没有结束他们对公寓楼的战争。随着多伦多在60年代向外扩张，城市规划者将住宅区指定为“不可侵犯”，意味着它们不能受到新开发项目的影响。
The only thing you can build there are single-family homes. It was a real statement of do not mess with our neighborhoods. On the city land use map, these in-violet neighborhoods were coloured in yellow. That's why for years Toronto has had something called the Yellow Belt. A sea of neighborhoods where new development was limited to detached single-family homes. According to House Devited, a book about Toronto's missing middle, the yellow belt in Toronto is more than twice the size of Manhattan. This yellow belt zoning stops Toronto from building more middle housing.
你唯一能在那儿建造的就是单户住宅。这确实是一种“别动我们的社区”的声明。在城市土地利用地图上，这些不可侵犯的社区被涂成了黄色。这就是为什么多年来多伦多一直有所谓的“黄带区”。一片海洋般的社区，新开发项目仅限于独立的单户住宅。根据关于多伦多“缺失的中产住宅”的书籍《分裂的房屋》，多伦多的黄带区面积是曼哈顿的两倍多。这种黄带区分区阻止了多伦多建造更多的中产住宅。
That's why we don't find a duplex or a low rise walkup on every corner. And that missing middle in Toronto has real consequences for the city. Urbanists say the lack of middle housing in Toronto has led to a divided city. If all you build are single-family homes, that makes lots of residential neighborhoods unaffordable. Historically, middle housing has been disproportionately useful for immigrant families and single women. Apartments provided women with the opportunity to access affordable housing more independently. So with single attached housing or even semi-attached housing, a woman will only be able to access that if they were living as a domestic servant or if they were a wife.
这就是为什么我们在每个街角都找不到复式公寓或低层步梯公寓。多伦多缺失的中产住宅对城市产生了真正的影响。城市规划者表示，多伦多缺乏中产住宅导致了城市的分裂。如果你只建造单户住宅，那会使许多住宅区变得难以负担。从历史上看，中产住宅对移民家庭和单身女性特别有用。公寓为女性提供了更独立地获得经济适用房的机会。因此，对于单户住宅甚至半独立式住宅，女性只有在作为家庭佣人或妻子的情况下才能获得。
Cheryl Case is one of the editors of the book House Divided. She says the missing middle has led to economic but also racial segregation in Toronto. So the missing middle has always been a race issue. So for evidence of this, you can actually look back into Thorncrest Village, which is a exclusively detached neighborhood that was built in Atobico. The neighborhood Cheryl is talking about
谢丽尔·凯斯是《分裂的房屋》一书的编辑之一。她说，“缺失的中产住宅”导致了多伦多的经济和种族隔离。所以，“缺失的中产住宅”一直是一个种族问题。关于这一点，你可以回顾一下索恩克雷斯特村，这是一个建在怡陶碧谷的纯独立住宅区。谢丽尔所说的社区
was one of the first real suburban communities built in Toronto in the 1940s. But it could be almost anywhere in the yellow belt. It's large, single-family homes surrounded by trees and greenery. You wouldn't know you're in a huge North American metropolis. And so in this neighborhood, people had to apply to buy housing there, and the people who were applying explained why they were applying to buy housing there, and they very directly explained that they were buying that housing,
是20世纪40年代在多伦多建造的首批真正的郊区社区之一。但它几乎可以是黄带区的任何地方。它有大型的单户住宅，周围环绕着树木和绿地。你不会知道自己身处一个巨大的北美大都市。在这个社区，人们必须申请才能购买住房，而申请的人解释了他们为什么要申请购买那里的住房，他们非常直接地解释说，他们购买那里的住房，
so they could escape the diversity of the other neighborhoods. Zoning might have been designed to protect these neighborhoods from change, but Cheryl says that even they suffer, while the city as a whole grows, these neighborhoods are actually losing population. It's a part of a broader picture, right, about living healthily and having a healthy communities. So right now, on the city of Toronto, you have schools closing all across the city, because these are neighborhoods that haven't seen any growth happening in them.
是为了逃避其他社区的多样性。分区法的设计初衷可能是为了保护这些社区免受变化的影响，但谢丽尔说，即使是它们也受到了损害。当整个城市都在增长时，这些社区的人口实际上在减少。这是一个更宏大图景的一部分，对吧，关于健康生活和拥有健康的社区。所以现在，在多伦多市，学校在全市范围内关闭，因为这些社区没有看到任何增长。
You might assume a lot of the city's housing woes could be explained by a lack of new construction. But anyone who lives in Toronto knows the city is building lots of giant condo towers. In fact, between 1996 and 2016, Toronto built housing at one and a half times the rate of population growth. In theory, these condos should provide more housing and bring prices down. And I have to think that it helps a little, but these new condos haven't fixed the city's housing lows. Toronto is still way behind in terms of housing availability and the legacy of banning most buildings that would have made up the missing middle is partially to blame. A report found that in 2020, Toronto had 360 housing units for every 1000 residents. That's well below the average for cities in G7 countries, which is 471 units for every 1000
你可能会认为城市许多住房问题可以用缺乏新建筑来解释。但任何住在多伦多的人都知道，这座城市正在建造许多巨大的公寓塔楼。事实上，在1996年至2016年间，多伦多的住房建设速度是人口增长速度的1.5倍。理论上，这些公寓应该提供更多住房并降低价格。我不得不认为这有一点帮助，但这些新公寓并没有解决城市的住房低迷问题。多伦多在住房供应方面仍然远远落后，而禁止大多数本可以构成“缺失的中产住宅”的建筑的遗留问题是部分原因。一份报告发现，2020年，多伦多每1000名居民拥有360套住房。这远低于G7国家城市每1000名居民拥有471套住房的平均水平。
residents. And those units that do exist in Toronto aren't bringing prices down. A one-bedroom apartment there rents for over $2,000 a month, and that number keeps going up. These units are not putting downward pressure on the price of a detached house either, which is around $2 million. For me, a big problem with these new condo towers is this. They only really serve a very narrow range of people. Most of the new residences being built are luxury. I hope you can hear the air quotes there. Luxury condos that only have one bedroom and are totally unsuitable for families. They also come with hefty monthly fees that make them unaffordable for lots of people.
而多伦多现有的那些单元并没有降低价格。那里的一居室公寓租金超过每月2000美元，而且这个数字还在不断上涨。这些单元也没有对独立屋的价格产生下行压力，独立屋的价格约为200万加元。对我来说，这些新公寓塔楼的一个大问题是：它们实际上只服务于极少数人。大多数正在建造的新住宅都是豪华的——希望你能听到那里的引号——只有一间卧室且完全不适合家庭居住的豪华公寓。它们还附带高昂的月费，使许多人负担不起。
Those small units only serve one type of market. Young, single professionals who want a clean, low effort place to live. Anyone else is kind of crowded out, and in the current market, that's all that gets built. I spoke to Nama Blonder. She's an architect and a planner, and she runs a company called Smart Density. She's all about the missing middle.
那些小单元只服务于一种市场：想要一个干净、低维护居住场所的年轻单身专业人士。其他人基本上被挤出去了，而在当前的市场中，这就是唯一会被建造的东西。我采访了娜玛·布隆德。她是一位建筑师和规划师，经营着一家名为“智能密度”的公司。她非常关注“缺失的中产住宅”。
She wants the city to be filling in those density gaps. I do believe condos, they belong in the city. They belong next to expensive infrastructure, such as transit. I have nothing against them. Yet, it seems like we're building a lot of units and they don't reflect the diversity that is currently needed in the city. When Namah says diversity, here,
她希望城市能填补这些密度缺口。我相信公寓属于城市。它们属于昂贵的基础设施旁边，比如交通枢纽。我并不反对它们。然而，似乎我们建造了很多单元，但它们并没有反映出城市目前所需的多样性。当娜玛在这里说“多样性”时，
she's referencing the types of units that are built. I've been scouring floor plans for proposed and in-progress developments, and they're largely tiny one bedrooms or bachelor's and studios. I want to call it misguided, but it's not really guided at all. Developers just can't build much else.
她指的是所建造单元的类型。我一直在搜寻拟建和在建项目的平面图，它们大多是微小的单间公寓、单身公寓和工作室。我想称之为“误导”，但实际上根本没有引导。开发商只是无法建造其他东西。
The thing is there are developers who want to build middle housing, but in most places, it's still illegal to build anything except for single-family homes, and in the places where you can put up taller buildings, all the incentives push you in the direction of giant condo towers. Jason Allen John is a mortgage broker and a developer in Toronto. He wants to build affordable housing in communities he cares about, like Toronto's Little Jamaican neighborhood.
问题在于，有开发商想要建造中产住宅，但在大多数地方，除了单户住宅外，建造任何东西仍然是非法的；而在你可以建造更高建筑的地方，所有的激励措施都把你推向巨大的公寓塔楼。杰森·艾伦·约翰是多伦多的一名抵押贷款经纪人和开发商。他想在他关心的社区（如多伦多的小牙买加社区）建造经济适用房。
You know, like my personal vision would be kind of cool if you turn into a massive, like business commerce hub for, you know, black individuals. Like, I think significant missing middle towers, a mix of condos, affordable ownership, commercial space, office buildings, all on that strip. Jason bought a site in Little Jamaica a couple of years ago. He wanted to kickstart the process of revitalizing the area by providing affordable mid-rise apartment buildings.
你知道，我的个人愿景是，如果你能把它变成一个巨大的商业中心，为黑人个人服务，那会很酷。比如，我认为显著的“缺失的中产住宅”塔楼，混合了公寓、经济适用房所有权、商业空间、办公楼，都在那条街上。杰森几年前在小牙买加买了一块地。他想通过提供经济适用的中层公寓楼来启动该地区的振兴进程。
So I wanted to say, oh no, you can do a project. That is consumer submittal and you can do a project. That is concert misimidial. And you can make a little, you can make some money. You can provide jobs for individuals and then also inspire people to do this themselves. But Jason's dream may never become a reality. Jason says every time he tries to get financing for a low-rise apartment complex, he's told by investors to build condos or single family homes instead. I've had to do a lot of convincing on the project itself because, you know, most people will tell me just do a nice single family dwelling and build it and sell it for 2.5 million or something, right? So that's kind of where everybody wants you to go. So it's like, no matter where you turn in a sense, people will be like, oh no, why don't you just do this? Even if you do get the financing, the approval process can take
所以我想说，哦不，你可以做一个项目。这是一个消费者提交的项目，你可以做一个项目。这是一个音乐会中产住宅项目。你可以赚点钱。你可以为个人提供就业机会，然后激励人们自己做这件事。但杰森的梦想可能永远不会成为现实。杰森说，每次他试图为低层公寓大楼融资时，投资者都会告诉他去建公寓或单户住宅。我必须在项目本身上做很多说服工作，因为你知道，大多数人会告诉我，只管建一个漂亮的单户住宅，建好后以250万左右的价格卖掉，对吧？所以这就是每个人都想让你去的地方。所以无论你转向哪里，人们都会说，哦不，你为什么不直接做这个呢？即使你确实获得了融资，审批过程也可能需要
years and there are incredibly high development fees. In fact, the city just proposed an increase to those fees of 49%. If it takes the same amount of time to get a hundred unit building approved as it does a ten unit building and there are huge fees associated with it either way, that destroys the already narrow profit margin on the smaller building. A bigger project has a bigger margin and can swallow the fees and delays more easily. Politicians in Ontario have done almost nothing to address this. The provincial government led by Doug Ford recently introduced a housing bill, but it ignores single-family zoning entirely. That might change. City planners have just drafted an amendment to allow up to a four-plex in protected neighborhoods, but it's a pretty conservative plan
几年时间，而且开发费用高得惊人。事实上，市政府刚刚提议将这些费用提高49%。如果批准一栋100个单元的建筑和批准一栋10个单元的建筑所需的时间相同，而且无论哪种方式都有巨大的相关费用，那就会摧毁小型建筑本已微薄的利润空间。更大的项目有更大的利润空间，可以更容易地消化费用和延误。安大略省的政客们几乎没有采取任何措施来解决这个问题。道格·福特领导的省政府最近提出了一项住房法案，但它完全忽略了单户住宅分区。这可能会改变。城市规划者刚刚起草了一项修正案，允许在受保护的社区建造最多四联排公寓，但这只是一个相当保守的计划，
with lots of caveats, and it's a long way from reaching the city council for approval. Of course Toronto isn't the only city with this missing middle problem. In fact, other cities with a missing middle have tried to take concrete steps to fix it. Cities like Portland, Oregon, which in recent decades has tried to make the city
有很多附加条件，而且距离提交市议会批准还有很长的路要走。当然，多伦多并不是唯一一个有“缺失的中产住宅”问题的城市。事实上，其他有“缺失的中产住宅”的城市已经尝试采取具体步骤来解决它。比如俄勒冈州的波特兰市，近几十年来一直试图让城市
more livable for renters. Camille Trummer worked with the mayor of Portland to pass zoning reform. And in the process, she became public enemy number one for NIMBies, the people who don't want new apartment developments in their neighborhood. There were campaigns cropping up in different neighborhoods across the city that were really if we want to be transparent, kind of firmly rooted in NIMBYism, not in my backyard. What do you think they were scared of?
对租房者更友好。卡米尔·特鲁默与波特兰市长合作通过了分区改革。在这个过程中，她成了NIMBY（邻避主义者）的头号公敌，这些人不希望在他们的社区有新的公寓开发项目。在城市各处的不同社区中，确实出现了一些运动，如果我们想透明一点的话，它们实际上是坚定地植根于NIMBY主义——“不要在我家后院”。你认为他们害怕什么？
To be honest with you, Jay, I think they were scared of low-income people moving into their neighborhoods and whatever serial types or narratives they've built through media consumption and lack of education and lack of interaction with people that are different than them, about who they believe those people are and what they would do to their neighborhoods.
老实说，杰伊，我认为他们害怕低收入人群搬进他们的社区，以及通过媒体消费、缺乏教育和缺乏与不同于他们的人的互动，他们所建立的关于他们认为这些人是谁以及他们会对他们的社区做什么的任何刻板印象或叙事。
Camille says Portland used to have the same exclusionary zoning laws as Toronto, and changing them was a real uphill fight for Mayor Charlie Hales. And what was so ironic is that many of Charlie's neighbors were the ones and the people most vocal in terms of the Nimbism group. So that was really challenging for Charlie to be unable to even talk with his neighbors about his vision. And so we saw a lot of manifestations of narratives and small campaigns advocating for status quo. To change the law, Camille had to build a coalition of people herself, people who weren't wealthy homeowners. So, she went out in the community and gathered herself a steering committee that looked a lot more like Portland. It was such a visual kind of challenge for me
卡米尔说，波特兰过去和多伦多有同样的排他性分区法，改变它们对查理·黑尔斯市长来说是一场真正的艰苦斗争。具有讽刺意味的是，查理的许多邻居正是那些在邻避主义群体中最直言不讳的人。所以这对查理来说真的很有挑战性，他甚至无法与邻居谈论他的愿景。因此，我们看到了许多叙事和倡导现状的小型运动。为了改变法律，卡米尔不得不亲自建立一个由非富裕房主组成的人员联盟。所以，她走进社区，为自己召集了一个看起来更像波特兰的指导委员会。对我来说，这是一个视觉上的挑战，
to be in that room and see so clearly. Yes, there are older white folks with privilege sitting on one side of the room. There's developers huddled in the corner, scheming, and then there's these housing advocates that represent such a diverse kind of illustration of Portland. It took a lot of work and a lot of politics, but the bill passed in 2020.
在那个房间里看得如此清楚。是的，房间的一边坐着有特权的老年白人。开发商蜷缩在角落里，密谋着，然后是这些代表波特兰多样性缩影的住房倡导者。这需要大量的工作和政治手段，但该法案在2020年通过了。
It ended single family zoning and allowed things like cottage clusters and small apartment buildings almost everywhere. If you want to tear down an old relic of a house and turn it into a fourplex, you can do that now. Congratulations, whether it used to be one home, now there are four. You've created some density, made some money, and today Portland is an oasis of affordable, missing middle housing. Right, Camille? I wish I could say that, Jay. Oh, damn, never mind. So why not? What's the hold up? Where's Portland's missing middle? The problem, I think, with our process is, yes, zoning codes go into effect, but the interpretation
它结束了单户住宅分区，并允许在几乎任何地方建造小屋群和小型公寓楼。如果你想拆掉一栋旧房子，把它变成四联排公寓，你现在可以这样做。恭喜，无论它过去是一个家，现在有四个了。你创造了一些密度，赚了一些钱，今天波特兰成了经济适用的“缺失的中产住宅”的绿洲。对吧，卡米尔？我希望我能这么说，杰伊。哦，该死，没关系。那为什么不呢？阻碍是什么？波特兰的“缺失的中产住宅”在哪里？我认为我们流程的问题在于，是的，分区法规生效了，但开发商，甚至是非营利性开发商、社区驱动的开发商对该分区法规的解读，
of that zoning code by developers, even nonprofit developers, community driven developers, means that there's a lot of calculations at play. How much is the cost of land? Can we actually create these things? And so what I would have loved to see is more incentives to actualize what is being proposed or what was proposed. While zoning reform isn't a silver bullet for a housing crisis, it is a big first step. American cities like Minneapolis and Seattle have also recently banned exclusive single-family zoning to address this problem head on. There is a different way of planning a city like Toronto. Namiblanda has a vision. One that more closely resembles the European cities I'm familiar with.
意味着有很多计算在起作用。土地成本是多少？我们真的能创造这些东西吗？所以我很想看到更多的激励措施来实现所提议或曾经提议的内容。虽然分区改革不是解决住房危机的灵丹妙药，但它是重要的一大步。明尼阿波利斯和西雅图等美国城市最近也禁止了排他性的单户住宅分区，以直接解决这个问题。规划像多伦多这样的城市有另一种方式。娜玛·布隆德有一个愿景。一个更接近我熟悉的欧洲城市的愿景。
I moved to Toronto eight years ago. And one of my first strongest impressions of the city was I took the subway, I got out and steps away from the subway. There are neighborhoods of single-family houses, sea of single-family houses. And for someone who, you know, I wasn't born in North America, it's a strange feeling. You just don't get it, right? It's you're in the downtown or steps away from the subway and you have this suburban feeling of instead of an urban feeling, right?
我八年前搬到多伦多。我对这座城市最初的最强烈的印象之一是，我坐了地铁，出来后离地铁站几步之遥。那里有单户住宅社区，一片单户住宅的海洋。对于一个，你知道，我不是在北美出生的人来说，这是一种奇怪的感觉。你就是无法理解，对吧？你就在市中心或离地铁站几步之遥的地方，你却有一种郊区的感觉，而不是城市的感觉，对吧？
Having this missing middle, and it's not just about height, it's not just about housing stock, it's also about opportunities of, for families, the missing middle of income or the missing middle of the units that currently don't exist. Even with different zoning laws and a lot of political will, it will still take years of planning and development to create new apartments for renters like Jay Coburn. Though at this point in the story, I have to make a confession. Against the odds, when I moved to Toronto, I actually did end up finding a walk-up. I'm on the second floor of an apartment building.
拥有这种“缺失的中产住宅”，不仅仅是关于高度，不仅仅是关于住房存量，它还关乎家庭的机会，收入的“缺失的中产住宅”或目前不存在的单元的“缺失的中产住宅”。即使有不同的分区法和大量的政治意愿，仍需要多年的规划和开发才能为像杰伊·科本这样的租房者创造新的公寓。虽然在故事的这一点上，我必须做一个坦白。出乎意料的是，当我搬到多伦多时，我确实最终找到了一栋步梯公寓。我在一栋公寓楼的二楼。
No exposed brick, but I do have high ceilings and a beautiful view of a beer store parking lot. I even know all of my neighbours. Sometimes we sit on the porch and drink wine. Heather deserves a special mention for feeding my cat when I'm away. There's just enough space for me, about 450 square feet. But I can step up my door without having to take an elevator, and immediately I'm next to a deli and some cute shops. It's not perfect, but I love living here,
没有裸露的砖墙，但我有高高的天花板和啤酒商店停车场的绝美景色。我甚至认识我所有的邻居。有时我们坐在门廊上喝红酒。希瑟值得特别提及，因为在我不在的时候她喂了我的猫。那里刚好有足够的空间给我，大约450平方英尺。但我可以走出家门而无需乘坐电梯，而且我旁边就是一家熟食店和一些可爱的商店。它并不完美，但我喜欢住在这里，
and I wish everyone could find a place that suits them. J's apartment is in one of the historic neighborhoods of Toronto, part of the yellow belt, but there are hints of how the city could have looked without the zoning laws. It's an area where the Victorian and the early 20th century buildings have been preserved. I live in the Cabbage Town neighborhood. It has this kind of toy town vibe. Lots of red brick houses with steeply-slow grooves and ornamental stained glass windows. It even has a few walk-up apartment buildings like mine, some actual missing middle. These were all built before the ban, and my building was finished
我希望每个人都能找到适合自己的地方。杰伊的公寓位于多伦多的历史街区之一，属于黄带区，但有一些迹象表明，如果没有分区法，这座城市本可以是什么样子。这是一个维多利亚时代和20世纪初建筑得到保护的区域。我住在卷心菜镇社区。它有一种玩具城的感觉。许多红砖房子，有着陡峭的屋顶和装饰性的彩色玻璃窗。它甚至有几栋像我这样的步梯公寓楼，一些真正的“缺失的中产住宅”。这些都是在禁令之前建造的，我的建筑是在
in 1912 right under the wire. My place is kind of odd because from the outside it looks like a regular detached house. But I checked and it's always been apartments. It's almost as if the builder was trying to hide its true nature. The walk-up entrances are even hidden around the back. Walking through the residential streets of Jays' neighborhood, you can see tiny examples of what the city might have been like without exclusionary zoning. Adding middle housing and residential neighborhoods can help make a city more functional. It allows for a bigger diversity of housing stock, and for families and middle-class people
1912年刚好赶在截止日期前完工的。我的住处有点奇怪，因为从外面看它像一栋普通的独立住宅。但我查了一下，它一直都是公寓。简直就像建筑商试图隐藏它的真实性质。步梯入口甚至隐藏在后面。走在杰伊社区的住宅街道上，你可以看到如果没有排他性分区，这座城市本可能是什么样子的微小例子。在住宅区增加中产住宅可以帮助城市变得更具功能性。它允许住房存量的多样化，并让家庭和中产阶级
to stay in town and add to the character of a neighborhood. But there needs to be political will and real effort to make it possible. When middle housing is effectively banned for 100 years, a lot of deliberate and careful planning is necessary to undo that damage to the city's ecosystem. No amount of zoning can freeze a place in time. The choice is how neighborhoods in Toronto will change, not if. Does the city tackle its housing crisis and create a vibrant place where lots of different kinds of people can live? Or does it become a suburban sprawl? On and on, paving over the landscape forever. More fun with zoning laws after this.
留在城里，增加社区的特色。但需要政治意愿和真正的努力来实现这一点。当中产住宅被有效地禁止了100年时，需要大量审慎和仔细的规划来消除对城市生态系统的破坏。没有任何分区法可以将一个地方冻结在时间里。选择在于多伦多的社区将如何改变，而不是是否改变。这座城市是解决其住房危机并创造一个多元化人群可以居住的充满活力的地方吗？还是它会变成郊区蔓延？不断地，永远地铺平景观。稍后会有更多关于分区法的乐趣。
So I am back with Jay Coburn. We're talking about zoning laws. Yeah, the most exciting topic there is. Well, it's exciting and that's important. And it shapes our lives. I think it's exciting. And that's why I've just spent half an hour talking about it. I totally agree. And actually, I wanted to talk about one of the most insane examples of Toronto City planning.
所以我又和杰伊·科本在一起了。我们在谈论分区法。是的，这是最令人兴奋的话题。嗯，它既令人兴奋又很重要。它塑造了我们的生活。我认为它很令人兴奋。这就是为什么我刚才花了半小时谈论它。我完全同意。实际上，我想谈谈多伦多城市规划中最疯狂的例子之一。
I found out about this from an article in The Toronto Star by their affordable housing report of Victoria Gibson, who just does really great work, by the way, just amazing coverage of housing in this city, where it's really important. But this story is dumb, not because she wrote it, but because of the content. Like, it's written very intelligently, but the story itself is depressingly dumb, and it really just makes you feel like what's going on in this city.
我是从《多伦多星报》的一篇文章中发现的，作者是他们的经济适用房记者维多利亚·吉布森，顺便说一句，她做得非常好，对这座城市的住房报道非常出色，这真的很重要。但这个故事很愚蠢，不是因为她写得不好，而是因为内容。就像，它写得非常聪明，但故事本身却令人沮丧地愚蠢，它真的让你觉得这座城市到底发生了什么。
Okay, tell me more, I'm prepared to be depressed by something so dumb. So there's a 17-unit apartment building in the Forest Hill neighborhood that the city insists is actually just two semi-detached houses. Okay, well you sent me a picture here, and it's, yeah, it's a beautiful pre-war building
好吧，多跟我说说，我已经准备好被这种愚蠢的事情搞得郁闷了。所以，在森林山社区有一栋17个单元的公寓楼，市政府坚持认为它实际上只是两栋半独立式住宅。好吧，你发给我一张照片，它确实是一栋漂亮的战前建筑。
and it has these little big window pop outs that's made a brick. It's lovely, you totally imagine a bunch of people living there, 17 families to be exact. So a previous owner decided they wanted to turn this apartment building into two semi-detached houses and the city approved it. But they never finished converting it to houses.
它有那种砖砌的小型大窗户凸出结构。很可爱，你完全可以想象有一群人住在那里，确切地说是17个家庭。所以，前任业主决定把这栋公寓楼改成两栋半独立式住宅，市政府也批准了。但他们从未完成改建工作。
So it's an apartment building, but legally nobody can actually live in the apartments. It's just empty, boarded up, and derelict. It has been for over a decade. The owner's just aren't allowed to use it for what it was intended for, which is as an apartment building. But it's definitely an apartment building.
所以它现在是一栋公寓楼，但在法律上没有人能真正住在这些公寓里。它只是空置着，用木板封住，破败不堪。这种情况已经持续了十多年。业主只是不被允许将其用于原本的用途，即作为公寓楼。但它绝对是一栋公寓楼。
There's no way you can look at this, and then it's anything other than an apartment building. If you look at it, it's four stories high, has individual balconies for individual units. This is not too semi-detached houses. It's only ever been used as apartments, and it was used as apartments from when it was built all the way up until 2006.
你不可能看着它，却认为它不是公寓楼。如果你看它，它有四层高，每个单元都有独立的阳台。这根本不是两栋半独立式住宅。它一直被用作公寓，从建成一直到2006年都是如此。
Why exactly can't they use it as it was intended to be built? Is this the zoning thing from the 1912 anti-apartment laws? Well, kind of. The street it's on wasn't included in the 1912 apartment ban, so it was built sometime around 1923-ish. We don't know exactly, it's kind of vague when you look at the records. This is a really small area around these apartments, by the way, just a few streets wide. But because it got there pre-that ban, it had this thing called legal non-conforming status, which means that as long as it's continually in use, it could continue to be an apartment building in a place that doesn't allow apartment buildings.
为什么他们不能按原定用途使用它？这是1912年反公寓法带来的分区问题吗？嗯，算是吧。它所在的街道没有被纳入1912年的公寓禁令，所以它大约是在1923年左右建成的。我们不确定具体时间，查看记录时有点模糊。顺便说一下，这些公寓周围的区域非常小，只有几条街宽。但因为它在禁令之前就存在了，所以它拥有所谓的“合法不符合现状”地位，这意味着只要它持续使用，它就可以在不允许公寓楼的地方继续作为公寓楼存在。
Oh, so icy. So it's the continually in use part that's really the issue here. Like the previous owner wanted to change it into two houses, the tenants left were evicted, and at some point, the building was technically not in use because no one was in it. Yeah, and this is part of why a lot of the city is actually getting less dense by the way.
哦，太冷酷了。所以“持续使用”才是这里真正的问题。比如前任业主想把它改成两栋房子，剩下的租户被驱逐了，在某个时间点，这栋建筑在技术上处于“未使用”状态，因为里面没有人。是的，这也是为什么这个城市的很多地方实际上密度正在降低的原因之一。
This isn't the only project like that. The zoning and bylaws do allow for removing housing options. And just reading over this star article, it looks like initially they wanted to do the opposite and nearly double the number of units to 31. But they changed their minds after a public consultation, which I don't even know how to respond to that. It means that they had a big meeting and a bunch of people yelled at them and told them. That's exactly what it means. Yeah. Okay. A lot of people who already owned houses didn't want other people to live in apartments. Yeah. So they got approval to convert it to two huge houses, knocked down some internal walls. I'm not sure exactly how much work they actually did inside, but they never finished the job.
这并不是唯一一个这样的项目。分区和附例确实允许减少住房选择。读了这篇《星报》的文章，看起来他们最初想做相反的事情，将单元数量增加近一倍，达到31个。但在公众咨询后他们改变了主意，我甚至不知道该如何回应。这意味着他们开了一个大会，一群人对他们大喊大叫，告诉他们……这正是它的意思。是的。好吧。许多已经拥有房子的人不想让其他人住在公寓里。是的。所以他们获得了将其改建为两栋大房子的批准，拆除了一些内部墙壁。我不确定他们实际上在内部做了多少工作，但他们从未完成这项工作。
Instead, they sold the property, and now this building is technically too ridiculously big, boarded up empty houses. So the people who bought that property, did they intend them to turn them into apartments or houses? Well, the new owners didn't like the two house things, so they applied for a minor variance in the by-law to turn it back into apartments. So they were going to go through the really lengthy process of consultations and city approvals. Like I mentioned earlier, it takes a really long time and as house prices have risen really fast, they've instead decided they can just sell the property and make them money that way instead.
相反，他们卖掉了房产，现在这栋建筑在技术上变成了两栋大得离谱、用木板封住的空房子。那么买下那处房产的人，是打算把它变成公寓还是房子？嗯，新业主不喜欢两栋房子的方案，所以他们申请了附例的微小变更，想把它改回公寓。所以他们本来要经历非常漫长的咨询和城市审批程序。就像我之前提到的，这需要很长时间，而且随着房价飞涨，他们反而决定直接卖掉房产，通过这种方式赚钱。
There's this quote in the star article from the owners. I'm an apartment guy. I like having apartments, and if we wanted to do things like the houses, which I could start on tomorrow, it's starting to make more sense that we should just stop fighting and beating our head against the wall to get apartments.
《星报》文章里有业主的一段话。我是个做公寓的人。我喜欢拥有公寓，如果我们想做像房子那样的事情，我明天就可以开始，但现在看来，我们应该停止抗争，不再为了获得公寓许可而碰壁，这似乎更有道理。
Well, it's reminiscent of that person you interviewed Jason Allen John, you know, like at a certain point, it just stops making sense trying to build apartments because all the incentives are pushing people to build either high-rise condos or single-family residences. And in this case, they can only build single-family residences. But what's pretty tragic about this is because there's already an apartment building there. You know, like, it just let it be an apartment. Yeah, it's nuts. And that's kind of why I wanted to highlight this one
嗯，这让人想起你采访过的杰森·艾伦·约翰，你知道，在某种程度上，试图建造公寓变得毫无意义，因为所有的激励措施都在推动人们建造高层公寓或单户住宅。在这种情况下，他们只能建造单户住宅。但最可悲的是，因为那里已经有一栋公寓楼了。你知道，就让它成为公寓吧。是的，这太疯狂了。这也是我为什么想强调这个案例的原因。
particular case. You can't look at this building and expect it to be anything other than apartments. But a combination of Byzantine municipal nonsense and economics means there are 17 potential units just sitting empty and forest hill who knows what the property will end up actually being used for It's on the market for $10.5 million right now as far as I can tell it was bought for $4 million 10 years ago That's not a bad return without really doing anything and it's kind of depressing that this turned out to be the best way for an investor to
你不能看着这栋建筑，却指望它不是公寓。但拜占庭式的市政荒谬规定和经济因素的结合，意味着在森林山有17个潜在的单元正闲置着。谁知道这处房产最终会被用来做什么。据我所知，它目前以1050万美元的价格挂牌出售，10年前它是以400万美元买下的。这回报率相当不错，而且几乎什么都没做。令人沮丧的是，这竟然成了投资者赚钱的最佳方式。
make their money. The building is just an asset, not housing, right? But it's taking up really valuable space in a city with an acute housing crisis. Yeah. Well, it's just another reminder that the incentives are all pushing the wrong behavior in people like we should be building housing and all the economic incentives and municipal bureaucracy should be like pushing people in that direction and it's really a shame when it doesn't happen. Yeah, it's not just pushing them in the wrong direction, it's prohibiting them from going
这栋建筑只是一个资产，而不是住房，对吧？但它在一个住房危机严重的城市里占据了非常宝贵的空间。是的。嗯，这只是另一个提醒，所有的激励措施都在推动人们做出错误的决策。我们应该建造住房，所有的经济激励和市政官僚机构都应该推动人们朝着这个方向努力，而当这种情况没有发生时，真的很遗憾。是的，这不仅仅是把他们推向错误的方向，而是禁止他们走向
what we might call the right direction. Yeah. They're literally not allowed to make this apartment building into apartments and it's infuriating. It really is. Well, thank you for that dumb depressing story, Jay. And the whole thing is really, really eye-opening. And I think it will apply to a lot of people's vision of their own cities and how to make them
我们可能称之为正确的方向。是的。他们实际上不被允许把这栋公寓楼变成公寓，这太令人愤怒了。确实如此。好吧，谢谢你讲这个愚蠢而令人沮丧的故事，杰伊。整个事情真的非常发人深省。我认为它适用于很多人对自己城市的看法，以及如何让它们
better. So, thank you. Oh, thank you, Roman. Thank you for listening to my dumb depressing story. 99% of what was produced this week by Jay Coburn, a researcher with Ann Beneroya, edited by Chris Baroupe, music by our director of sound Swan Riau, mixed in tech production by Amida Ganatra, and fact-checking by Graham Haysha. Executive producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, the rest of the
变得更好。所以，谢谢你。哦，谢谢你，罗曼。感谢你收听我这个愚蠢而令人沮丧的故事。本周的节目由杰伊·科本制作，研究员是安·贝内罗亚，编辑是克里斯·巴鲁普，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里奥创作，混音和技术制作由阿米达·加纳特拉负责，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。执行制片人是德莱尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，其余的
team includes Vivian Leigh, Martin Gonzales, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashmodon, Jason Dalyone, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Charlotte Mickey and Jennifer Franks for their warm welcome at Spadina Gardens and to John Lawrence, editor of the book, House Divided, a great resource if you want to know more about this issue. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius exam podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown Oakland, California You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99 PI org. We're on Instagram and read it too
团队成员包括薇薇安·李、马丁·冈萨雷斯、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、拉什莫丹、杰森·戴利恩、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。本周特别感谢夏洛特·米奇和詹妮弗·弗兰克斯在斯帕迪纳花园的热情接待，以及《分裂的房子》一书的编辑约翰·劳伦斯，如果你想了解更多关于这个问题的信息，这是一本很好的参考书。我们现在是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰上城区，向北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。
You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI dot org. T-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t- There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在99PI dot org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI的每一期往期节目。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。